sarah's with us in raleigh north
carolina hey sarah welcome to the ramsay
show
hi thanks for taking my call my pleasure
how can we help
so um we just recently heard about your
plan
in this last year and we've worked
really hard and we've
got rid of 20 000 in credit card debt
and have about 6 000 left
and the problem is is that
recently well about 10 years ago my
in-laws gave us
ten thousand dollars when we were
getting out of medical school
and my husband was going to get his
first job and we're moving across the
country
and they said okay just pay this back
whenever you have it it's not a big deal
well
recently we offended them and they won
their ten thousand dollars back
so we don't have they didn't
let's rephrase this when someone says
give it back to me later
that's not a gift that's a loan
okay right you just pay us back whenever
no big deal
right that's a loan
isn't it right yeah they loaned you
money
and uh so uh but it just didn't have
really good clarity and good
communication and good terms there was
no
date certain no interest rate no
payment rate nothing it was just you
know pass back someday when you can
yeah right right yes okay and how many
years ago was this
10 10 years and you told me that and i
already forgot alright
and so uh your household income now is
what
it's about 150 and you have six thousand
dollars left plus this ten right
um yes of all we have a mortgage and we
have a car payment
oh car payment is part of the debt
snowball hunt so
six thousand dollars plus a car what do
you owe in your car
um we it's around thirty thousand
mm-hmm okay all right so you have thirty
six thousand forty six thousand dollars
in debt and you make a hundred and fifty
yeah
yes how much do you have in your savings
right now
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
okay okay sarah hold on i got this dave
i got this dave
so sarah when we asked this question on
how much debt did you have that's
everything excluding a mortgage okay so
you're new to us so i want to step in
before you know
you know uncle dave comes in uh so so
your brother is going to come in and
help you out here
so how much debt do you have excluding
your mortgage
right now all together okay
so um 6 000 um
credit card 30 000 the car payment and
about 100 000 in student loans we went
from
6 000 america 236 thousand dollars in
debt
forty six years a hundred father-in-law
yeah uh-huh
goodness gracious okay so here's the
thing that and i'm gonna say this too
because you're just starting off with
this you're gonna work the debt snowball
and you're going to put the ten thousand
dollars inside of that debt snowball
so you think she ought to pay him back i
mean well if it was a loan
yeah did it sound like to you she said
give it back to us later
that's a loan to me okay i'm just making
sure we heard the same thing
okay am i wrong no no no i'm just just
checking
you know checking in with you i wish you
can see since you're running
interference here i thought i'd check it
out
about to say uncle dave over here
looking at you know brother dave i mean
anthony over here like what was she
thinking
um but yeah i think you need to add that
in there
until so to answer your direct question
yes you need to pay it back
um and i think
family owing family money compared to
owing a bank money
is worse in my opinion because it just
creates so much more drama
and so i want you to get to it as much
as possible
um as quick as possible but what is the
uh
six thousand dollar debt yeah
that's six what is that that's a
it's a um normal credit card
it's a low rate okay and then you have
another thirty thousand on a
one single credit card no that's a car
that's the card
good okay all right cool so our debt
snowball sarah that we teach the fastest
most efficient way to get out of debt is
list your debts
smallest to largest regardless of
interest rate and attack them in that
order do you all have any money
in savings that is not retirement i bet
you they do
um we have a
roth ira not
written no
how much money do you have in your
checking account right now
um about ten thousand
okay that's a pretty good bet all right
so what would i do if i woke up in your
shoes today
is how we answer questions here knowing
what i know of 30 years of teaching
people to become wealthy
the shortest distance between you and
wealth is to be debt-free
before not counting your mortgage as
soon as possible
because if you had no payments making
150 000 you'd have some money agreed
right okay so we're going to list the
debts smallest to largest and attack
them out of order today i'm going to
write a check and pay off the 6000
credit card by the way you need to cut
it up and close
it and only use a debit card you can't
get out of that while you continually go
back in
okay yeah and we're well on our way for
that one
i think thing number two is you're gonna
as soon as possible in the next two
months write a check and pay off your
in-laws
now okay here's the problem
the only reason they want the money back
now is they're trying to punish you
because you didn't mind
them right they told you to do something
and it offended them right
what was it well
um because we've kind of seen a pattern
of behavior they
wanted to move to the same town with us
and we said that we didn't think that
was a good idea
so they were very very upset
yeah their feelings so what was the path
what's the pattern of behavior
um just that they get offended very
quickly and easily over small things and
we were like if you're living right next
to us they're gonna
you know they're going to be upset at us
for this or that and things like this
are going to happen
for the rest of our lives for their life
so go ahead and give them a big thing to
be offended at like don't move to my
town
that's not a little one that's a big one
okay yeah that would hurt most people's
feelings so
you've already drawn some uncomfortable
boundaries with them
um that you felt were necessary uh
and i'm not saying they weren't but um
so you telling them when you're going to
pay back
a loan that you choose to pay back on a
moral ground
not a legal ground because they have no
legal standing in this at all
this was a handshake yeah okay right
so you get to choose the terms
okay uh so in other words no you don't
get to choose to punish me by doing this
but i will honor your request and repay
the loan
uh on my terms you don't have to say it
that way but you just take that stand
and your terms happen to be that it's
the next thing
on your list of things to do since you
paid off your credit card
today okay and then you're gonna save up
real quick like
i mean one month or two months and
you're gonna write one check
for ten thousand dollars and be sure in
the four column
to put paid in full
okay that just says another message for
them to be offended about but just in
case
in case they decide to come back and go
now we want interest
or whatever because this is all they're
getting
right and they're not getting
anything else so
because i'm not having you pay them back
because their feelings are hurt
i'm having them pay i'm having you pay
them back because you were
obligated to do that morally anyway when
you took the money
it was a loan and we're all in agreement
on that are we not sarah
yes yeah even though you don't really
want to because they're
instituting this on pure punishment and
they're being childish
i don't blame you for those feelings but
i'm executing i'm executing on principle
here
and on mathematics and let's just go
ahead and get this out of the way oh and
by the way now you're free the
borrower's slave to the lender
and you're not anymore beholden and so
now you can be kind
and strong and gentle with them and
continue to set
appropriate boundaries